today marks one year since an American
newlywed became a prisoner of Venezuela
the case has now become a focus for the
Trump administration police in Caracas
arrested Josh Holt last summer on
weapons charges he was also accused of
trying to undermine Venezuela's
government Holt's family says the 25
year old traveled from Utah only to
marry his fiancee Toni Tecopa
spoke with his parents Toni good morning
good morning Jason and Laurie Holt say
their son learned Spanish as a Mormon
missionary and look forward to a life
with his new Venezuelan bride instead
they say he's become a hostage and a
political pawn please Lord just bring
him home
please let this end put my family back
together
Lori Holt and her husband Jason aren't
sure they can bear another year of worry
over the safety of their imprisoned son
Josh for mother you can't even explain
how much it hurts at all I would trade
places in a heartbeat with with him you
know I've lived my life let him come
back to live his now they were initially
optimistic when they learned their son
had been arrested last summer I
literally thought okay just sit down
we'll get him home in the next couple
weeks he's innocent there's no way that
they can look at this kid look in his
background and find anything that he's
done Jason and Lorie say Josh travelled
to Venezuela to married tomorrow Candela
a woman he had met online I think at
that age you still haven't experienced
life yet and you do things for love that
maybe somebody at our age wouldn't do
you just went down there to marry his
love of his life and started his own
life but about two weeks after the
wedding Venezuelan police raided the
apartment Holt's shared with his new
wife claiming to find an ak-47 and a
hand grenade police arrested the couple
later on state television Interior
Minister Gustavo Gonzalez called Holt a
gringo and linked him to unspecified us
attempts to undermine embattled
president Nicolas Maduro that sound like
Josh he's a vibrant kid I always had a
smile on his face
my stew room up he's a comedian that is
our best memories of sitting around our
island
just cracking jokes that has not been
something that we've done literally in a
year because there's nothing to crack a
joke about as the months rolled by
Josh's parents say he grew sicker in
prison dropping more than 50 pounds in a
letter he described a horrible place
where a demon strolled the hallways he's
been in great God he's been angry at our
government he's very depressed he has at
times been suicidal today I humbly asked
the new Trump administration in January
Laurie Holt issued a plea to the White
House and the family has been pleased
with the Trump administration's interest
in the case I can't get any higher than
what I've gotten in our government I
literally have reached the top and
cannot go any further still they're
calling on the President to do more
please push harder push harder because
we need this to be over we need him to
be home we need to be home as a family
again
if Josh happens to see this for some
reason what would he want him to know
how much we love him Holt's wife Tamarra
is also in prison and Tamara's mother
who lives in Venezuela says she believes
her daughter and son-in-law were framed
CBS News called the Venezuelan
government's press office in Caracas for
comment on this story and the operator
transferred us to someone but no one
ever picked up the phone Gail glad
you're telling this story Tony people
are now listening hopefully it will lead
to a good resolution there thank you
very much